Das muss man jetzt mal so zur Kenntnis nehmen, damit ist das Projekt beendet.
Für mich, das sage ich ganz klar, ist das eine Niederlage der Zentralfamilie.
Dabei sollte uns bitte die nächste Zeit niemand mehr irgendwie mit Solidaritätsthemen kommen, denn solidarischer, wie wir uns hier aufgestellt hatten, gerade die großen Klubs, solidarischer kann man nicht mehr sein.
Dann im Nachgang beleidigt die Leberwürste, sich in der Pressekonferenz dann auch hinzusetzen. Also ganz ehrlich, das ist auch nicht in Ordnung, wenn man einer solchen großen Verantwortung gerecht werden will.
Wenn man aus einer Pressekonferenz solche O-Töne herausziehen kann, wie die gerade gehörten, und dann jemand wie Andreas Rettich dazu sagt, was für beleidigte Leberwürste, dann ist etwas passiert, was mindestens ein paar Menschen emotionalisiert hat im deutschen Fußball. Und damit Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 52. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und ich habe mich in den letzten Wochen und besonders Tagen intensiv mit dem möglichen Einstieg eines Investors in der deutschen Fußballliga beschäftigt, zu dem es jetzt nicht kommen wird. Denn am Mittwoch, dem 24. Mai, hat sich eine ausreichende Minderheit an Clubs dagegen gewährt oder dagegen ausgesprochen, den Prozess einzuleiten, mit diesem Investor oder sich diesen Investor zu suchen und in konkrete Verhandlungen zu treten. Und damit ist diese Sache vom Tisch. Und all das hat aber hohe Wellen geschlagen. Ihr habt schon ein paar O-Töne gehört und ihr werdet auch noch einige in diesem Tribünengespräch hören. Denn wir wollen heute mal die Fragen beantworten. Worum ging es da eigentlich? Warum hat die Liga geglaubt, das wäre nötig? Und was folgt denn jetzt daraus, dass in einer so wichtigen Entscheidung sich kein Konsens gefunden hat in der Liga? Zumindest kein breiter Konsens. Eine Mehrheit hat mit 20 Stimmen dafür gestimmt, diese Investoren-Idee weiter zu verfolgen. Die restlichen 16 haben sich entweder enthalten, fünf Stück oder elf haben dagegen gestimmt. Um was geht es? Es geht letztlich darum, die audiovisuellen Rechte nennt man das. Also sagen wir einfach die TV-Rechte. Wir wissen ja, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, dass damit auch Streaming gemeint ist. Sowohl die nationalen, das spricht, dass man in Deutschland die Bundesliga gucken kann, als auch international, also dass ich zum Beispiel in den USA die Bundesliga gucken kann. Diese Rechte plus noch einige kommerzielle Rechte sollten in eine eigene Gesellschaft ausgelagert werden. Und an dieser Gesellschaft sollte sich ein Investor beteiligen. 12,5 Prozent hätte er sich sichern sollen für anvisierte 2 Milliarden Euro auf 20 Jahre hin. Was bedeutet das? Die Liga hätte eben in mehreren Tranchen dieses Geld, diese 2 Milliarden bekommen und dafür hätte der Investor für 20 Jahre 12,5 Prozent der Einnahmen eben dieser Rechte erhalten. Das heißt, man verkauft im Grunde zukünftige Gewinne, um sie jetzt investieren zu können. Und was man damit alles machen wollte, und wie das genau ausgestaltet werden sollte, das müssen wir jetzt alles im Detail nicht mehr so genau besprechen, wie es vor dieser Entscheidung der Fall war. Wir werden es in diesem Tribünengespräch ansprechen und das Ganze versuchen für euch einzuordnen. Und dafür habe ich mehrere Gäste, die ihr jetzt dann im Anschluss hören werdet. Zum einen Marcus Bark und Chaled Nahar, die ihr beide ja auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk kennt, renommierte Sportjournalisten, die sich tief in diese ganze Thematik eingegraben haben. Und dann habe ich aber auch noch drei Interviews geführt, die ihr in Ausschnitten hören werdet. Und zwar mit Michael Ströll, dem kaufmännischen Geschäftsführer des FC Augsburg, mit Andreas Rettig, unter anderem ehemaliger DFL-Geschäftsführer und mit Ilya Kentzik, er ist Geschäftsführer beim VfL Bochum. Begleitend dazu habe ich noch ein paar Hintergrundgespräche geführt mit weiteren Vertretern, das haben die anderen auch getan. Und das alles binden wir jetzt hier zusammen in einer Sendung, die euch hoffentlich ein paar Lichter aufgehen lässt und aber auch klar macht, welche Tragweite jetzt das hat, was da passiert ist am 24. Mai. Und passend zu einer Investoren-Sendung, bin ich stolz und glücklich zu verkünden, dass wir zum allerersten Mal in der Rasenfunk-Geschichte einen Sponsor haben. Sponsor dieser Folge des Tribünengesprächs Nummer 52 seid ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ja, ich gib's zu. Das war jetzt ein lauer Gag der Rasenfunk. Er ist und bleibt natürlich paywall, werbe- und sponsorunfrei. Ihr wisst es doch alle. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auch eine Sendung wie diese hier. Also diese Sendung noch mehr als viele andere Sendungen im Rasenfunk war nur möglich, weil ich mich mit all meiner Zeit dem Rasenfunk widmen kann, weil ich Zeit habe für Recherche und weil ich auch Zeit habe für Gespräche und Recherche, die vielleicht gar nicht an eine Sendung gemündet hätten. Es gab keinen Zwang, ein Tribünengespräch daraus zu machen. Das alles ist nur möglich, weil ihr uns unterstützt. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. In dieser Ausgabe möchte ich denken, danken Schiffskatze und Nick1898. Sie haben uns nicht nur unterstützt, sondern sich auch noch registriert als Supporterinnen und Supporter auf rasenfunk.de supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann? Am liebsten per Banküberweisung, per Dauerauftrag. Dann kommen auch wirklich von den 5 Euro 5 Euro bei uns an. Die wir verwenden können. Das Geld ist nicht nur für mein Gehalt und für Frank, sondern wir zahlen ja auch unseren Gästen Honorarie. Ihr wisst, was wir inzwischen alles im Rasenfunk machen. Im Grunde gibt es im Rasenfunk kaum noch ein Thema des Fußballs, das nicht irgendwie behandelt wird. Also wir machen Männerbundesliga, Frauenbundesliga, Europäische Männertop-Ligen, zweite Männerbundesliga machen wir. Wir machen zeitlose Dinge wie das hier, was ihr jetzt hier gerade hört. Und das alles immer, zumindest im Versuch, das alles auf einem Niveau zu machen, das euch dann auch gefällt. Also bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk und hört den Rasenfunk und empfiehlt den Rasenfunk weiter. Und ergänzend zu dieser Sendung, gleich geht es auch los, ich verspreche es, möchte ich euch noch ein weiteres Tribünengespräch empfehlen. Die Zukunft des Fußballs war ein Thema eines Tribünengesprächs, an dem ich glaube acht Monate gearbeitet habe. So ganz genau weiß ich es gar nicht mehr. Viele Dinge, die wir heute besprechen, die bekommen noch mal einen anderen Beigeschmack, wenn man sich dieses Tribünengespräch entweder schon angehört hat oder danach noch mal zu Gemüte führt. Denn ich glaube viele Debatten, auch die wir hier führen, die basieren auf einer Grundannahme des Fußballs, nämlich dass er auf einer Wachstumslogik basiert, die zumindest hinterfragt werden kann. Man muss sie nicht problematisieren, aber hinterfragen sollten wir sie doch von Zeit zu Zeit. Das tun wir im Tribünengespräch Zukunft des Fußballs, das zu außerordentlich interessanten Diskussionen schon geführt hat. Bei uns im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die dort schon mitdiskutiert haben. Das muss jetzt aber reichen mit der Vorrede. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß jetzt mit diesem Tribünengespräch. Jetzt gleich geht es los und wir hören Marcus Bark und Chaled Nahar. Jetzt habe ich bei mir Chaled Nahar und Marcus Bark, die geballte Kompetenz, was das Thema Investoreneinstieg bei der DFL angeht. Also nicht nur dabei die geballte Kompetenz. Marcus, schön, dass du mal wieder hier bist.
Und die Premier League verdient erstmals mit den Auslands-TV-Rechten mehr als mit den nationalen TV-Rechten.
Genau, das war der große Paradigmenwechsel zuletzt. Und wenn wir dann darüber sprechen, diese OTT-Plattform, also der legendäre mittlerweile Topf 1 zur Internationalisierung, Digitalisierung, Verjüngung, das ist ja erst mal auch kein Topf zur Digitalisierung, das ist ein Topf zum Geldmachen, das dürfen wir nicht vergessen. Darum geht es. Und diese OTT-Plattform, die ist ja nicht nur in Deutschland ein Thema. Die Premier League will sowas angeblich auch einrichten. Und in diesen ganzen Fußball-Business-Portalen liest man halt so Hoffnungen von 15 Millionen Kunden, die im Jahr bereit sind, 100 britische Pfund zu zahlen. So, nimm den Taschenrechner, da ist das ganze Desaster vollumfänglich da. Und dann reden wir nicht von einem Rückstand, dann reden wir wirklich von mehreren Planetenabstand zu England. Und ich glaube, diese Befürchtung besteht, dass man halt auch dieses Element verpasst, OTT-Plattform, so ein eigenes Ding zu sein. Die FIFA hat ja auch sowas. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt. FIFA Plus, das kann man sich mittlerweile auch auf Fernsehern installieren. Es gibt, glaube ich, UEFA, TV. Da kommen meistens nur Auslosungen und sowas, weil ja die meisten Rechte für alle in Europa vergeben sind. Aber FIFA Plus zeigt dann zum Beispiel, wenn sie mal zufällig gerade den TV-Vertrag für die afrikanische WM-Qualifikation zersägt haben, dann kommt das da, oder?
Die WM in Katar, die Männer-WM konnte man doch in Brasilien, glaube ich, nur bei FIFA Plus sehen oder auch bei FIFA Plus.
Oder nehmen wir an, es kämen keine TV-Verträge in bestimmten Ländern für die Frauen-WM zustande. Könnte es sein, dass die FIFA dieses Portal nutzt, um diese Sender entsprechend unter Druck zu setzen?
Das muss man vielleicht kurz sagen, OTT ist eben genau das. OTT ist Over-the-Top-Content, das ist quasi das, also letztlich Streaming.
Genau, dass man im Grunde so einen Leak Pass macht, wie die NBA oder so was. Und wenn man dann auf die anderen Ligen guckt, also die Unterschiede sind gar nicht mal so groß. Die Spanier haben ein bisschen mehr und da wird ja auch immer der kulturelle Vorteil angesprochen. Die halbe Welt spricht Spanisch, die andere Hälfte spricht Englisch. Dazu kommt Arabisch und Chinesisch wahrscheinlich. Und da hat Deutsch keinen internationalen kulturellen Platz, wo die Liga dann so verfangen könnte. Also das Schicksal von Norwich City und Rayo Vallecano liegt weltweit vielleicht mehr Leuten am Herzen als das des VfB Stuttgart. Muss man vielleicht so anerkennen. Aber wenn man auch sieht, wie die Bundesliga teilweise in England ankommt, dass Leute hier rüberreisen, um sich die Spiele anzusehen, dann kann ich auch verstehen, wenn die sagen, so völlig chancenlos sind wir auch nicht und ambitionslos wollen wir auch nicht sein, wir versuchen es mal. Und gerade wenn man sieht, mit welchen Summen die Englander da rechnen, ist es weiterhin, glaube ich, kein Fehler, zumindest in dieses Feld zu gehen ein bisschen.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist es, glaube ich, wichtig, da die Zahlen noch mal so grob zu ordnen. Weil du hast jetzt schon damit angefangen, weil das ist die Marktsituation, in der sich eben die Bundesligisten befinden. Sie sind eben nicht nur auf dem nationalen Markt, sondern auf dem internationalen Markt. Die Premier League ist für immer davon, du hast es schon gesagt. Und wenn wir uns dann die nationalen TV-Rechte angucken, dann liegen eigentlich Bundesliga, La Liga, Serie A ungefähr gleich auf. Das ist so ungefähr bei einer Milliarde. Ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen weniger verteilt man es dann auf die ganzen Vereine. Das ist dann der Unterschied nicht mehr so krass. Die Liga hinkt noch ein bisschen hinterher, aber die hatten auch wirklich Probleme mit Media Pro. Die hatten ihre Raten einfach nicht überwiesen. Jetzt sind die Spiele bei Amazon Prime. Also wenn ihr euch da noch mal einlesen wollt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war auch spektakulär, wie das damals verstanden gegangen ist. Das sind die nationalen TV-Rechte, also sprich auf dem eigenen Markt. Und jetzt kommt das Interessante, weil das ist ja der Bereich, wo auch die besorgniserregende Entwicklung stattfindet für die Bundesliga und zwar die internationalen TV-Rechte. Also sprich, wer im Ausland möchte die Bundesliga sehen? Premier League haben wir schon gesagt, noch viel mehr als national, das ist völlig absurd. La Liga, rund 900 Millionen Euro pro Saison. Also auch fast noch mal das, was man auch auf dem nationalen TV-Markt bekommt. Und dann eine deutliche Lücke. Serie A, aktuell 205 Millionen Euro pro Saison. Und die Bundesliga, rund 200 Millionen, manchmal sagen sie 170, manchmal sagen sie 176, habe ich jetzt auch schon gehört. Wichtig dazu ist aber zu wissen, mir wurde aus mehreren Quellen gesagt, dass bei der letzten TV-Rechtevergabe man gerade auf dem internationalen Markt eigentlich davon ausgegangen ist, Richtung 400 Millionen, vielleicht sogar 450 Millionen Euro hochzugehen von 263 oder so. Und stattdessen ist man runtergegangen. Und das ist das, was so ein bisschen versteckt war, weil wir im TV-Vertrag immer viel über nationale TV-Verträge und die TV-Gelder reden. Aber das muss wohl das gewesen sein, wo einigen das Monokel aus dem Auge gefallen ist oder die Kaffeetasse aus der Hand. Da hat die Bundesliga wahrscheinlich zu Recht eben Sorge, dass wirklich auch andere Ligen sie abhängen.
Ich glaube, das kann man ja ganz deutlich ablesen bei diesen UEFA-Unterlagen. Also, der alte Auslandsvertrag war 840 Millionen durch drei Jahre. Könnt ihr gerade mal ausrechnen, während ich weiter laber. Und jetzt sind es 683 Millionen für vier Jahre, also ein kleinerer Betrag für einen längeren Zeitraum. Das ist eine klare Ausland-TV-Rechte-Rezession, der man entgegentreten möchte.
Also ich habe da nämlich auch drüber nachgedacht, weil wir wissen ja auch, dass der TV-Vertrag mit Bay in Sports sehr lukrativ war rund um gewisse Turniere, die stattgefunden haben. Und das war so ein Gedanke, den ich hatte. Aber das ist reinst der Spekulation von mir. Ich habe dazu nichts rausfinden können.
Also sie sind, das kann man sagen, wenn man es auf pro Saison runterrechnen möchte, diesen UEFA-Unterlagen zufolge als Quelle wohlgemerkt. Im Jahr 2021 kam der Neuabschluss. Und dann ist der jährliche Betrag von 280 auf 170 Millionen Euro pro Saison gesunken.
Genau, das sind die 170. Also das ist eben die Situation. Tatsächlich haben wir da eine Lücke, die entsteht zu den anderen Ligen. Und dann möchte ich, und das mache ich jetzt aber kurz, da rausche ich jetzt nur so ein bisschen durch, damit die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, was machen denn die anderen Ligen? Denn weder La Liga noch Serie A noch die Ligue 1, keiner von denen ist zufrieden mit dem, was sie haben, obwohl sie ja zum Teil deutlich mehr haben als Deutschland. Und da sehen wir eben, aha, die haben eigentlich alle das gemacht, was jetzt hier geplant war. In der Ligue 1 hat im April 2022 CVC, also eben diese Investoren, diese Private Equity-Firma, 13 Prozent für 1,5 Milliarden Euro übernommen. Davon hat dann die Liga auch schon die erste Tranche erhalten. Ich habe vorhin schon genannt, welche Kosten dabei aufgekommen sind, aber wir merken uns 13 Prozent, 1,5 Milliarden Euro in der Ligue 1 für ein ganz ähnliches Modell. Wir lagern die Rechte aus. Der Investor kann sich mit dran beteiligen. Wir investieren dieses Geld. Ehrlicherweise bei der Ligue 1 sprechen die sehr deutlich drüber, dass sie erst mal damit Schulden ticken. Das ist sowohl in der Ligue 1 als auch in La Liga eigentlich so der Plan. Die sprechen gar nicht mehr von Infrastruktur, aber das ist da passiert. Dann gucken wir nach Spanien. Da hat im Dezember 2021 wie das CWC 1,99 Milliarden Euro, also fast die zwei Milliarden, die ja auch hier immer so als Zahl im Raum hingen, für eine Beteiligung an La Liga ausgegeben. Die Hälfte davon haben sie auch schon ausgezahlt. Sie bekommen dafür 8,2 Prozent der Anteile für 50 Jahre. Das ist im Private Equity Bereich auch gar nicht so unüblich, dass man so lange Laufzeiten hat, also davon nicht irritieren lassen. Interessanterweise, da haben drei gegen diesen Deal geklagt. Real Madrid, Barcelona und Athletic Bilbao. Deswegen gibt es da noch so einen kleinen Rechtsstreit, der anhängig ist, aber La Liga macht genau das. Und die sollen beim Game Pass schon relativ weit sein. Wobei man nie so genau weiß, was man Sebastian Präsidenten so glauben sollte, in eigentlich allen Belangen, die er sagt. Aber angeblich orientieren sie sich am NBA Game Pass und wer den schon mal verwendet hat, weiß, das ist technologisch dann schon ein gehobener Fortschritt und könnte sich für La Liga auszahlen. Und dann haben wir noch die Serie A. Da gab es den Plan, dass der Liga-Präsident Paolo Dal Pino wollte zehn Prozent eben auch wieder an TV und kommerziellen Rechten an ein Konsortium aus. Nicht nur CWC, sondern diesmal auch Advent und Fondo FSI. Das ist eine italienische Investmentgruppe verkaufen und damit 1,6 Milliarden Euro erlösen. Es haben dann angeblich sieben Clubs wollten seinen Rücktritt. Der Deal ist gescheitert. Da sind einige Dinge schiefgelaufen. Sie waren auch mit den Zahlen nicht einverstanden. Das ist verbrieft. Alle anderen Dinge sind ein bisschen gerüchtet. Deswegen ist es in der Serie A noch nicht zu nötig gekommen. Aber wir sehen eben, Ligue 1, La Liga und Serie A haben im Grunde genau das gemacht oder zumindest probiert es zu tun, was jetzt auch die DFL gemacht hat. Marcus, kann es sein, dass sich die Bundesligisten einfach nur nach links und rechts umgeschaut haben, gesagt haben, das wollen wir jetzt auch, weil nicht, dass die damit irgendwie den Heiligen Gral gefunden haben und wir müssen uns vorwerfen lassen in zehn Jahren, dass wir das nicht gemacht haben?
Kann durchaus sein. Also wir Deutschen hängen ja eh bei vielen Sachen hinterher und machen dann was, was andere sind. Ich meine, dass wir bei der Digitalisierung der hinterher sind, das ist ja nicht nur im Fußball so. Ja, gut möglich. Es ist natürlich eine Form, Geld zu bekommen, ohne sich zu verschulden. Ich meine, das hat Watzke ja auch gestern noch mal sehr deutlich gemacht. Er will keine Schulden machen und er versteht auch eigentlich nicht, warum so viele Leute dagegen sind. Weil ja auch gesagt wird, wenn unser Geschäftsmodell nicht trägt oder aus irgendwelchen Gründen Dialöse, die wir uns erhoffen, nicht kommen, dann trägt der Investor sogar das Risiko mit. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es im Ausland war, wie dieser Prozess abgelaufen ist, wie da die Medien, die Fans zustanden. Das kann ich nicht genau beurteilen. Aber klar, es deutet einiges darauf hin, dass man sich das zum Vorbild genommen hat, weil das sehr schnell sehr viel Geld gibt. Aber die Deals da laufen ja auch noch nicht so lange, als dass man die Befürchtung jetzt, dass man sagen kann, ihr habt euch umsonst die Sorgen gemacht, weil die Erfahrung hat noch keiner. Also ich weiß nicht, im US-Sport, der US-Sport ist ja sowieso anders gelagert, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Beispiel dafür gibt, dass das über einen sehr langen Zeitraum gelaufen ist. Die Formel 1 gibt es halt und da ist massiv Einfluss genommen worden. Ich habe ein Interview mit Bernie Eccleston, den muss man natürlich mit Vorsicht genießen, aber der hat gesagt, ich habe alles dafür getan, damit mein Investor, meine Private Equity Gesellschaft, den größtmöglichen Profit davon trägt. Und ob man sich das jetzt zum Vorbild nehmen sollte, weiß ich nicht. Also genau kann ich dir die Frage nicht sagen, aber klar, der Deal hat mit Sicherheit auch Vorteile gehabt. Das ist ein Vorteil, wenn man sich nicht verschuldet. Und wenn man sich verschuldet, muss man halt das Risiko alleine tragen, wenn der Investor das tatsächlich so macht. Aber der Zeitraum ist halt zu lange, als dass man da seriös was zu sagen kann. Und davor haben wir wahrscheinlich in Deutschland, das muss man natürlich sagen, wir sind viel konservativer in Deutschland als andere Länder. Wir haben ein ganz anderes Verhältnis auch zu Pay-per-view, beispielsweise in England, da zahlen die einfach verschiedene Abos, die teurer sind als hier. Und wir regen uns halt auf, wenn gut, da zahlen hat verdoppelt den Abo-Preis. Aber das sind ganz andere Kulturen und ich glaube, dass man das deshalb auch alles schwierig vergleichen kann.
Ja, und gleichzeitig landen wir damit ja aber dann auch bei der Frage nach den Alternativen. Also wir wissen jetzt, also so ein Investoren Deal, wie es einige der anderen Ligen gemacht haben, wird es nicht. Die Premier League braucht das alles nicht, die bekommen so schon sehr viel Geld. Und jetzt stellt sich aber dann die Frage, ja, wie kann es denn jetzt weitergehen? Denn die Probleme bleiben ja da, dass man eben die Angst hat, den Anschluss zu verlieren. Und dazu habe ich ein paar Töne mitgebracht von meinen Gesprächspartnern. Vielleicht beginnen wir mal wieder mit Michael Streu vom FC Augsburg, der sagt dazu Folgendes.
Der macht sicherlich Sinn, eben zu schauen, wo können wir die erste und zweite Liga zukunftsfähig aufstellen. Aber es muss nicht automatisch der Fall sein, dass ein Investor dadurch mit an Bord geholt wird. Sondern es gibt natürlich verschiedene Kapitalbesorgungsmöglichkeiten. Es muss auch nicht reines Fremdkapital sein, weil das ja gestern auch auf der PK so ein bisschen dargestellt wurde. Also wenn es das alleinige Szenario wäre, der 1. FC Köln glaube ich, hatten dann Vorschlag gemacht, eine Mischform eventuell an den Start zu bringen, wo Themen wie Bundesliga, Namensrechte vermarktet werden können über die nächsten Jahre. Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, die Abgaben an die DFL zu erhöhen, über einen gewissen Zeitraum der nächsten Jahre, um das Ganze von innen zu finanzieren. Aber dafür ist es meiner Meinung nach enorm wichtig und alles entscheidend, sich überhaupt damit auseinanderzusetzen. Was wollen wir als Verbund der 36 Clubs in der ersten und zweiten Liga? Welche Strategie wollen wir? Und erst, wenn wir uns mit der Frage intensiver beschäftigen und intensiver auseinandersetzen, dann können wir die anderen Fragen diskutieren.
Chaled, ist das nicht erstaunlich? Die Idee der ganzen Investoren kommt aus der AG-Zukunftsszenarien. Die wurde besetzt von vier Männern aus der DFL. Darin saßen Jan Christian Dresen vom FC Bayern, Rüdiger Fritsch vom SV Darmstadt 98, Axel Hellmann von Eintracht Frankfurt und Oliver Lecky vom SC Freiburg. Aus dieser AG kommt der Vorschlag des Investors. Jetzt ist ja Zukunftsszenarien plural. Ich habe das Gefühl, auch wenn ich Michael Streu zuhöre, es wurde bisher nur über diese eine Sache gesprochen. Er sagt jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so unrecht, wir müssen jetzt erst noch mal alle zusammen miteinander sprechen, was wir eigentlich wollen.
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass bei der DFL auf der Arbeitsebene unter der Spitze, da arbeiten teilweise sehr, sehr kluge Leute und die haben diese Szenarien auch gegenübergestellt. Also da bin ich mir sehr sicher, dass sie zumindest mal darüber gesprochen haben werden. Aber was mich halt wundert und dieser Oton gerade aus Augsburg, der zeigt es ja eigentlich genau, ist, dass offensichtlich zu keiner Zeit wirklich Raum war für einen Kompromiss irgendwie. Also wenn man sich diese ganzen ewigen Verhandlungen ums Financial Fair Play oder um die Champions-League-Reform anguckt oder andere sportpolitische Dinge und wie jetzt dieser Prozess in den letzten Wochen, das hat Markus ja eben gesagt, in wenigen Wochen derart Fahrt aufgenommen hat und man erst im Grunde 45 Minuten nach dem geplanten Beginn der entscheidenden Sitzung von dem Prinzip abrückt, was geplant ist und es ein bisschen offener gestaltet, ein bisschen Raum für Diskussionen lässt, das hat mich sehr gewundert und von daher diese Vorschläge, die gehen ja eigentlich auch in die Richtung, dass man sagt, ja, was alle sagen, Topf 1, also diese Digitalisierung, die ist halt sinnvoll, aber die Einnahmen aus der Zukunft auszugeben, das Geld von Clubs auszugeben, Und die später erst mitspielen vielleicht aus der dritten Liga eines Tages in mehreren Jahren, die wir gar nicht gefragt haben und die auch gar nicht beeinflussen können, dass sie später weniger einnehmen, obwohl sie überhaupt keinen Einfluss auf die Entscheidung genommen haben. Ja, das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und dieser Raum für eine Diskussion, den wollte man ja erst geben, als es zu spät war. Der neue Antrag des Präsidiums, der hieß ja dann, ja, wir können reden über die Partner, wir können reden über den Zeitraum, wir können reden über die Geldverteilung. Plötzlich war es möglich, über all diese Dinge zu diskutieren. Der einzige Kompromiss im Vorfeld, der sich angedeutet hatte, war ja, dass diese ganzen Zahlen so ein bisschen kleiner wurden. Zu Beginn der Diskussion vor einigen Wochen hieß es immer 25 bis 30 Prozent, dann war die Rede von zwei bis drei Milliarden, dann war die Rede von 25 bis 30 Jahren und so weiter. Und diese ganzen Zahlen, die schrumpften ja mit der Zeit, je näher diese Sitzung dann kam. Und der Zielkorridor, der war ja mal ein ganz anderer. Und jetzt waren diese Zahlen offenbar ein unausgesprochenes Zugeständnis schon. Und dann war man nicht bereit, noch weiter zu gehen. Aber da wäre vielleicht am ehesten die Lösung zu finden gewesen, irgendwelche Elemente davon noch durchzubekommen. Aber das ist jetzt klar verpasst worden. Da muss man sich jetzt andere Gedanken machen, wie man das umsetzt, dieses Ziel zu erreichen, was ja weiterhin da ist, jugendlicher, internationaler und digitaler zu werden. Und um mehr Geld zu verdienen, das ist das Hauptziel.
Es steht ja ein Businessplan dahinter. Und da finde ich, hat Andreas Rettich einen sehr guten Punkt gemacht.
Wenn die vorgelegten Businesspläne der Gruppen oder der Interimgeschäftsführung realistisch sind, dann spricht man da ja von einem durchschnittlichen jährlichen Wachstum von 7 bis 7,5 Prozent in der Frage. Mir erschließt sich jetzt nicht, warum das nicht mit anderen Optionen, Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten und Strategie nicht zu heben sein soll. Deswegen gehe ich davon aus, dass man sich auch, wie das jeder gute Geschäftsführer auch macht, mit dem Plan B beschäftigt. Mir ist er nicht bekannt.
Kleiner Seitenhieb noch am Schluss. Das ist ein klassischer Rettick, würde ich sagen. Aber das Argument ist ja tatsächlich treffend. Wenn im Businessplan drin steht, wir brauchen nur fünf Jahre die Zahlungen an den Investor vorfinanzieren, weil dann werden die ganzen Rechte schon so gestiegen sein, dass wir mindestens auf Null rauskommen, sondern eher besser. Warum soll diese Steigerung nur durch den Einstieg eines Investors möglich sein?
Es sind Alternativen aufgezeigt worden. Aber die Wachstumspotenziale haben auch nie konkret benannt worden. Und die 7,5 Prozent sind jetzt, glaube ich, das ist eine Zahl aus diesem Papier, was uns vorliegt. Da wurden der sogenannte Base Case berechnet. Das ist der Fall, dass kein Investor einsteigt. Da war die Wachstumsrate 2,8 Prozent und der Growth Case lag halt bei 7,5 Prozent. Und das erschließt sich nicht nur Andreas Rettig, sondern glaube ich ganz vielen Menschen nicht. Warum nur durch einen Investor, mit dem noch keine Sekunde direkt verhandelt wurde, gesagt wird, wir brauchen den unbedingt, um von 2,8 auf 7,5 zu kommen, ist mir ein Rätsel und war, glaube ich, sehr viel ein Rätsel.
Noch dazu, weil, da müssen wir jetzt nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen, aber CWC ist der einzige sportnahe Investor, der auch Sportinvestments hat. Der steckt aber halt in allen anderen Ligen mit drin. Also welchen Vorsprung soll man dann vor diesen Ligen erarbeiten? Und die anderen sind alle Private Equity Firmen, die vor allem in Deutschland, da eher im Gesundheitsbereich unterwegs sind oder die Deutsche Glasfaser hat einem gehört. Also müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, weil es würde jetzt nicht zum großen Investoren-Screening kommen. Aber da war jetzt auch keiner von den Investoren mit dabei, eben neben CWC, wo ich meine Einschränkungen schon gemacht habe, wo ich jetzt gedacht hätte, oh ja, die stehen wirklich dafür, dass sie ein Sport-Unterhaltungsprodukt oder überhaupt ein Unterhaltungsprodukt so nach vorne bekommen. Das sind einfach so riesige Firmen, denen halt einfach tausend Dinge hören, vom Rollstuhlhersteller bis hin zum großen Pharmakonzern. Und da wäre die DFL eine unter Tausenden gewesen. Also ich finde das auch sehr bemerkenswert, dass das auch so möglich ist. Ich weiß nicht, Chaled, spricht das vielleicht auch dafür, dass die diejenigen, die das vorangetrieben haben, und ich denke da kann man auf jeden Fall Hellmann und Leckie nennen, sicherlich auch Watzke, dass sie vielleicht unterschätzt haben, wie zurückhaltend die anderen Vereine oder manche der anderen Vereine sind, auch wenn man ihnen Geld vor die Nase hält.
Ja, das Geld, das vor die Nase gehalten wurde, war ja damit verbunden, dass die gleichzeitig sehen konnten, welches Geld den anderen dann zusteht. Und es ist halt, wenn der Kuchen insgesamt größer wird durch diese vorgezogenen Einnahmen und die Anteile, aber so bleiben wie bisher, dann wachsen logischerweise die Lücken. Da muss man kein Mathe-Professor für sein und das kriegen auch Drittligisten und Zweitligisten hin, das auszurechnen. Also es ist von daher, glaube ich, war diese diese Furcht, dass der Zweck der Übung war, den Großen was zuzuschustern, das war zu durchschaubar, glaube ich auch. Und diese Frage, die stellte sich ja auch von der Investor-Seite so ein bisschen vielleicht. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, wovon profitiert ein Investor, ist es für ihn wichtig, dass Eintracht Braunschweig vielleicht mal Platz 5 in der 2. Bundesliga belegt? Wahrscheinlich nicht. Für ihn ist es wichtig, dass die Bayern und Borussia Dortmund national wie international glänzen und somit das Interesse steigern. Sie berufen sich ja bei der Tatsache, dass sie so viel Geld kriegen, natürlich auch genau darauf, dass sie die Zugpferde sind, dass sie das Geld reinbringen. Das ist die gleiche Diskussion bei der Verteilung in der Champions League. Warum kriegt Manchester City so viel mehr als Villareal? Klar, weil die Leute für Manchester City bezahlen, in den Ländern, um das zu gucken. Aber letztendlich bleibt es dabei, wenn die Kleinen sich so abgehängt fühlen und sie haben derzeit dieses Stimmrecht in der DFL, dann ist es auch ihr gutes Recht zu sagen, ne, so wollen wir es nicht, weil das zerstört die Gleichstellung im Wettbewerb zwischen den Clubs.
Und da ist jetzt das Interessante, dass im Nachgang dieser ganzen Entscheidung fast genau die gegensätzliche Argumentation gefahren wurde. Also du hast ja gerade sehr gut herausgearbeitet, wie sowohl durch die Geldverteilung, als auch wahrscheinlich durch die Interessen des Investors, die großen Clubs, eher profitiert hätten als die kleineren Clubs. Und ich spiele jetzt mal zwei O-Töne ein von der Pressekonferenz. Einmal hören wir Axel Hellmann und einmal hören wir Aki Watzke. Und da klingt das, als wäre dieser ganze Investoren-Deal nur dafür da gewesen, um genau das Gegenteil zu bewirken. Hören wir einmal hier Hellmann.
Also da muss man ja kein Prophet sein, dass aus dieser Entscheidung heute die Zentralplattform nicht zu stärken und in die Zentralplattform Bundesliga zu investieren und die Zentralvermarktung zu stärken. Die wirtschaftliche Leistungsfähigkeit der jeweiligen Clubs entscheidend darüber sein wird, wie ihre Wertschöpfung aussieht. Und dass Vereine, die zum Beispiel international spielen und dafür auch, wenn ich mir die nächsten Ausschüttungen anschaue aus den UEFA-Wettbewerben, dann weiß ich doch, dass das, was heute passiert, die Schere in der Bundesliga eher auseinandergehen lässt, als die Klammer und die gemeinsame Plattform zu stärken. Für mich, das sage ich ganz klar, ist das eine Niederlage der Zentralvermarktung.
Eine Niederlage der Zentralvermarktung, sagt Axel Hellmann, und wenig später sagt Joachim Watzke das.
Meine Leute haben mir relativ deutlich die letzten Monate ausgerechnet, was das Borussia Dortmund jährlich kosten würde, und bei Bayern war es ähnlich. Ich glaube, wir haben der Liga die ausgestreckten Arme entgegengereicht. Wir hätten definitiv dabei die meisten Beitrag leisten müssen. Wir hätten das auch getan, um der Solidarität zu übeln. Aber jetzt, wo das eben nicht erwünscht ist, werden die größeren Clubs sich sicherlich auch darüber Gedanken machen, wie es dann für sie weitergeht. Aber es sollte uns bitte die nächste Zeit niemand mehr mit Solidarität kommen, denn Solidarische, wie wir uns hier aufgestellt hatten, gerade die großen Clubs, solidarischer kann man nicht mehr sein.
Marcus, was ist denn da los, dass wir drei uns so sehr mit diesem Thema befassen und das nicht erkannt haben, bevor dieser Deal geplatzt ist, dass das eigentlich eine große Solidaraktion ist, der großen Vereine für die kleinen Clubs?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich schon bemerkenswert, weil es wurde ja viel darüber geredet, wie wird das Geld verteilt. Und es wurde dann bei dieser ersten Veranstaltung der DFL mit Hellmann und Lecky gesagt und zugegeben, das läuft annähernd wie beim aktuellen Verteilerschlüssel. Und da wurde dann eigentlich nie mal drüber geredet. Ja, okay, wenn wir dieses Projekt retten wollen oder sagen wir mal sicher über die Brücke 24. Mai bringen wollen, dann sind wir vielleicht mal solidarisch und geben von unserem größten Batzen aktueller Verteilerschlüssel was ab. Das war nie Thema. Also das hat auch kein Zweitligist oder irgendjemand gesagt. Klar, das wurde dann so ein bisschen verklausuliert. Wir brauchen gerecht einen Wettbewerb oder so. Aber es hat nie jemand gesagt, passt auf, Bayern, München, Borussia Dortmund, gebt ihr was von eurem Kuchen ab, verteilt es anderen. Es hat ja auch nie einer gesagt, wir müssen das Geld gleich verteilen. Also Eintracht Braunschweig weiß genau, dass sie weniger kriegen als Bayern München. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns einig, das ist auch irgendwo schon gerechtfertigt. Und da gibt es gute Argumente für. War aber nie Thema. Und von daher, ob das jetzt so solidarisch ist, dann zu brohnen, ja, wir gehen jetzt in die Einzelvermarktung, weiß ich nicht. Kann aber auch gut sein, vielleicht werden wir dies heute schon ein bisschen bereuen, weil ich glaube, die waren auch so geschockt von der Entscheidung, dass sie so ein bisschen unter diesem Eindruck, ja, das war ja noch nicht mal eine Stunde danach, vielleicht so reagiert haben. Ich denke mal, in den nächsten Interviews wird das ein bisschen diplomatischer schon sein.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass es sehr aus der Kränkung herauskam. Also es sei ja auch für die in großen Teilen überraschend. Das haben sie ja auch so ein bisschen dargelegt. Darf man nicht ganz außer Acht lassen, was zum Beispiel hier Christian Seifert gesagt hat, der frühere Geschäftsführer, da gab es einen Text im Kicker zu. Ich weiß, ich habe jetzt den Titel der Veranstaltung vergessen, sonst würde ich sie korrekt zitieren, es tut mir leid. Da hat er gesagt, dass die Interessen so groß sind und dass die Struktur der DFL möglicherweise verändert werden müsste. Wir sind wieder beim Thema Super League-Rhetorik. Das ist natürlich auch wieder eine Frage. Muss die Struktur verändern? Ich meine, es ist wie bei der Wahl vom FIFA-Präsidenten. Da ärgern wir uns hier, dass Papua New Guinea die gleiche Stimme hat wie der DFB. Aber genauso könnte sich jetzt Hans-Joachim Watz geärgern, dass der 1. FC Magdeburg das gleiche Stimmrecht hat wie Bayern München. In die Richtung geht das ja fast. So viel zum Thema Demokratie in der Stelle. Es ist schwierig, glaube ich, da auch eine gerechte Lösung zu finden, wenn wir über diese Geldverteilung sprechen. Bei der Zentralvermarktung. Marcus meinte gerade, wir sind uns einig, dass dieses Leistungsprinzip ja irgendwie gelten soll. Finde ich auch. Aber das Leistungsprinzip ist an einer gewissen Stelle halt auch ausgehebelt worden, wenn wir darüber sprechen, was mit der europäischen Kohle passiert. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist ja seit einem Jahr immer Bochum 30 Millionen, Bayern 90 Millionen aus der DFL. Okay, kann man vielleicht als korrekt betrachten. Wenn dann die Bayern aber 110 Millionen Euro aus Europa bekommen, plus Merchandising, Tickets, Sponsoring und so weiter, sind die Unterschiede einfach irgendwann zu groß. Und dann gehen wir einen Schritt weiter. Wie sind diese Unterschiede eigentlich so groß geworden, gerade auf europäischer Ebene? Das ist ja der legendäre 10-Jahres-Koeffizient, der 2016 in einer Zeit der völligen Führungslosigkeit der UEFA als Platinie zurückgetreten war, eingeführt wurde und ganz viel Geld, fast ein Drittel der Champions League Kohle, an die großen Clubs transferiert, ohne dass sie irgendwas dafür machen müssen, außer ihre alten Ergebnisse von vor zehn Jahren zu präsentieren. Und dieses Prinzip ist neulich von der UEFA nochmal öffentlich verteidigt worden in so einem Finanzmedia-Briefing, an dem ich teilnehmen durfte. Da wurden alle Zahlen als die große Solidarität und Gerechtigkeit auch dort wieder runtergerechnet und so funktioniert dieses ganze System. Und diese Verschiebung in den letzten Jahren, die stattgefunden hat, dass immer mehr Geld zu den ganz Großen kommt, wofür es Gründe gibt. Klar, man kann so argumentieren. Warum zahlen Menschen in Malaysia Geld für TV-Abos? Weil sie Manchester City gegen Real Madrid sehen wollen. Sie wollen nicht Young Boys Bern gegen CFR Klutsch sehen. Klare Sache. Aber wer da mitspielt, diese ganze Aufregung, der Wettbewerb, bis wir bei den letzten Spielen sind, die entscheiden, ob Manchester City oder Paris Saint-Germain oder Real Madrid gewinnen, diese Aufregung dahin, die ist ja Teil der Wortschöpfung. Diese Aufregung tragen ja die Kleineren mit. Wenn sie irgendwann so abgehängt werden, dann ist es nicht mehr aufregend. Dann habe ich zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ich mache das mit dem Geld anders oder ich ändere den ganzen Wettbewerb, so wie es jetzt in der Champions League passiert, was auch eine Play-Off-Diskussion in der Bundesliga wäre. Noch eine andere Möglichkeit wäre, eine dritte wäre die Kostenschraube. Das hat Axel Hellmann, wo ich glaube, dass er ziemlich recht hat, in Dortmund ganz gut gesagt. Die Kostenschraube ist eigentlich fast die entscheidende. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, Jahre, wenn nicht Jahrzehnte lang, wurde uns allen immer wieder erzählt, Salary Cap sei das unrealistisch, das juristisch niemals zurechtfertigende, das unmögliche Mittel und plötzlich kommen von Alexander Schäferin über Hans-Joachim Watzke und Axel Hellmann alle mit dem Salary Cap an. Das wundert mich dann schon. Also scheint das ja doch eine Möglichkeit zu sein. Und es ist auch nicht gesagt, dass man nicht an zwei Schrauben gleichzeitig drehen kann. Man könnte die einen Namen anders verteilen und zugleich die Kosten reduzieren und damit auch eine OTT-Plattform finanzieren.
Ja, und das ist ja das Interessante, dass dann Christian Seifert natürlich jetzt in einer anderen Position als früher, aber dass er eben sagt, naja, es gibt ja sowieso das große Problem, es gibt zehn Vereine, die denken international, ich paraphrasiere jetzt, und der Rest tut das nicht und dementsprechend passt das nicht. Und dann macht er eben dieses mögliche Szenario auf, was ja auch zum Beispiel Watzke angedeutet hat, wenn er darauf hindeutet, dass davon anzunehmen ist, dass das Wahlverhalten der Zweitlegisten für diese Ablehnung mitentscheidend war. Oder auch zum Beispiel Oliver Lecky, der ja wirklich nicht viel gesagt hat, aber der einmal so eine Andeutung gemacht hat, wo ich mir auch die Frage gestellt habe, wo möchte er denn eigentlich damit hin?
Das muss man jetzt mal so zur Kenntnis nehmen, damit ist das Projekt beendet. Was das für die Zukunft und was das an Konsequenzen mit sich bringt, das ist für uns einigermaßen zu erahnen, aber auch noch nicht so hinreichend zu präzisieren, um das jetzt auch öffentlich zu dokumentieren. Aber damit werden wir jetzt erstmal umgehen müssen, und damit muss die ganze Liga umgehen.
Also die ahnen es schon, und wir müssen noch spekulieren. Aber es kann eben in mehrere Richtungen gehen. Es kann eben die Strukturreform sein, dass man eben dann die Solidargemeinschaft beendet und vielleicht erste Liga, zweite Liga voneinander trennt. Es gibt auch andere Möglichkeiten. Es kann auch in die andere Richtung gehen. Und da würde ich ganz gerne, weil das scheint mir jetzt so das zu sein, was jetzt das Relevante ist für Gegenwart und Zukunft, nämlich die Frage, naja, wie geht jetzt die DFL damit um, dass sie in einer so großen und wichtigen Entscheidung aus den verschiedensten Gründen, wir haben sie besprochen, nicht zu einem Konsens gelangt ist. Wie geht sie damit um? Das wird ja jetzt dann die kommenden Monate und wahrscheinlich auch Jahre prägen. Und ich würde gerne zum Einstieg da nochmal Michael Stroll anspielen, der dazu auch im Interview mit mir einiges gesagt hat. Und dann könnt ihr gerne mal eure Gedanken ergänzen, was jetzt dann eigentlich passieren könnte, müsste, sollte in der DFL.
Wir haben ja in den letzten gefühlt zehn Jahren genau diesen Ansatz verfolgt unter Christian Seifert, sechs bis zehn Top-Clubs europäisch zu platzieren. Und der Erfolg war ja da auch überschaubar, wenn man über Titel spricht. Und von daher ist es genau diese Diskussion, die wir führen müssen. Was wollen wir denn? Wollen wir eben möglichst viele international spielen lassen können? Wir durften ja auch mal das Vergnügen haben, an die Enfield Road zu reisen. Ich glaube, das hat weder uns geschadet, noch dem deutschen Fußball. Wir sind ganz knapp ausgeschieden. Also wir haben auch da, obwohl wir budgetär total unterschiedliche Welten hatten, die da aufeinander getroffen sind, hätten fast mit dem Freistoß von Stafi Liedersen 1 zu 1 in Liverpool erreicht. Und wären dann in die nächste Runde eingezogen, hätten dann Manchester United gespielt. Das ist ja genau das, was es ausmacht. Vor fünf Jahren hätte wahrscheinlich auch keiner gedacht, dass Eintracht Frankfurt die Europa League gewinnen kann. Da haben sie sich nur irgendwo im Abstiegskampf auch zum Teil befunden. Oder jetzt im SC Freiburg und Union Berlin zwei Vereine, die da oben niemand erwartet hätte, die spielen jetzt um den Einzug in die Champions League. Das kann doch genauso ein Antrieb und ein Anreiz sein für eine interessante Bundesliga und auch einen interessanten Zusammenschluss von 36 Clubs oder mehr. Aber das muss man diskutieren und das muss man zulassen und das muss man wollen. Und nicht vorab schon Interessen versuchen zu platzieren. Und ich glaube, das ist gestern das Zeichen, das dabei rausgekommen ist, dass man es nicht, dass die Kleinen gegen die Großen irgendwo versuchen zu agieren, sondern dass man einfach breiter diskutieren muss und einfach einen breiteren Konsens finden muss, um die strategische Richtung über die nächsten 5, 10 oder 20 Jahre zu finden.
Marcus, deckt sich das so mit den Dingen, die du gehört hast, jetzt im Nachgang zu diesem Scheitern des Investor und Deals?
Ja, größtenteils schon. Ich stolper immer über das Wort Strategie. Ich glaube, dadurch, dass das so häufig genannt wird, wird auch klar, dass sich die Bundesliga oder die DFL, die ja sehr heterogen ist, aber irgendwo immer noch nicht klar ist, wo wollen sie überhaupt hin, was wollen sie für einen Fußball? Da gab es mal eine Studie, die hatte genau diesen Titel, welchen Fußball wollen wir? Ich hatte das heute auch nochmal geschrieben, die Grundsatzfrage, will man mehrere Mannschaften, die jedes Jahr in der Lage sind, das Viertelfinale Champions League erreichen, oder will man eine Liga mit acht Mannschaften, die Chancen haben, Deutscher Meister zu werden? Darunter auch mal wieder Eintracht Frankfurt oder der 1. FC Köln, der ja vor ein paar Jahren auch mal dann Fünfter wurde. Und beides ist nicht unter einen Hut zu bringen. Will man Bier und Bratwurst mit Fan-Kultur und Ultras, oder will man halt einen, und das muss man glaube ich inzwischen so sagen, will man einen Club, der ohne 50 plus 1 sich den Staaten öffnet und die Kohle annehmt, egal wo sie herkommt. Ich glaube, es gibt dazwischen kein erfolgsversprechendes Modell. Und deshalb, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen sehr romantisch, glaube ich, dass man einfach mit weniger zufrieden sein sollte und sagen, wenn wir einen Fußball bieten können, an dem die Leute, die ins Stadion gehen Spaß haben und dass sich zumindest noch halbwegs viele Leute angucken, dann reicht uns das. Und ich will jetzt nicht Leverkusen zu nahe treten, das ist ja auch ein bisschen platt, aber habt ihr das Gefühl gehabt, dass sich viele Leute für den Halbfinale von Bayer Leverkusen im europäischen Wettbewerb interessieren? Es hat nur für Aufsehen gesorgt durch die Verlegung. Und das ist halt Stichwortstrategie, wo man drüber nachdenken will. Wenn wir oder wenn die DFL wirklich sagt, wir wollen ganz groß raus und wir wollen nicht nur, dass Bayern München mal die Champions League gewinnen kann, wenn es gut läuft, dann brauchen wir so viel Kohle. Ich glaube, da gibt es keinen anderen Weg, als 50 plus 1 fallen zu lassen. Ich helfe das für den falschen Weg, deshalb Stichwort. Man muss doch nicht mal demütig sein. Man muss halt einfach seine Erwartungen ein bisschen runterschrauben. Man muss das Produkt sich so zusammenschrauben, dass der heimische Markt, der ja viel, viel größer ist als der ausländische, einfach zufrieden ist. Und da gibt es keinen Konsens, weil die beiden Großen halt denken, wir müssen internationale Titel holen können. Und von daher, ich habe keine Antwort auf die Frage, wie die DFL das regeln will. Die nächsten Monate werden auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr spannend.
Ich glaube, da sind wir bei so ein paar Themen, die so ineinandergreifen. Leichter Widerspruch auf jeden Fall bei 50 plus 1. Ob das die einzige Lösung ist, um mitzuhalten? Ich weiß nicht, ob es eine Lösung ist, um mitzuhalten, ob es überhaupt eine Chance gibt, in dem Sinne, da noch mitzuhalten, dass die Staaten...
Ich habe nicht gesagt, mitzuhalten, sondern um die Champions League zu gewinnen. Um vielleicht zwei Vereine zu haben aus der Liga, die in der Lage sind, die Champions League zu gewinnen. Da sehe ich momentan nur eine, und die hat es auch geschafft, in den letzten Jahren, aber ist auch häufig schon früher gescheitert.
Ja, das meinte ich auch, aber gut, die Bayern, denen geht es nun auch weiterhin relativ gut finanziell. Also ich weise nur darauf hin, dass sie im Viertelfinale gegen Villarreal ausgeschieden sind und am Ende mehr als 30 Millionen Euro mehr als Villarreal bekommen haben aus ihrer Saison der Champions League, was auch ein interessanter Teil dieser Geldverteilung wieder ist. Was ich damit meine ist, die ganz großen Player, die sind ja eigentlich versorgt. Der Staatsfonds von Katar, von Saudi-Arabien und von Abu Dhabi, die haben jetzt alle ihre Clubs. Was bleibt denn noch, um mit diesen Clubs auf Augenhöhe zu bleiben? Bleibt dir nur noch der totale Super-Hedgefonds aus den USA vielleicht? Und was fällt mir noch ein, der Staatsfonds von Singapur oder so? Mehr Ideen habe ich langsam nicht mehr und dann kriegst du halt Triple Seven oder so. Das ist halt so mein Gedanke dabei. 50 plus 1. Ja, du sagst, es gibt diese zwei Wege, diese Weggabelung, da hast du auch völlig recht. 50 plus 1, da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich auch einig. Halten wir alle für erhaltenswert und für den richtigen Weg. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass die Abschaffung, vielleicht außer bei Bayern München, wie du sagst, ein oder zwei Clubs, da könnte es dann noch einen Schub geben, wenn die sich jemanden gönnen, der das so gut kann. Aber wen willst du holen? Und wenn man generell die ganze Liga darauf vorbereiten möchte, europäisch anzugreifen, also eine geschlossene Liga finanziell zu stärken durch eine Abschaffung von 50 plus 1, ich glaube dann erliegt man auch diesem Gedanken, dass das für alle besser wird, aber es werden ja weiterhin nur eine bestimmte Zahl an Clubs europäisch spielen und eine Menge Clubs absteigen, also weiterhin. Also es ist ja, ob das dann am Ende so zielführend ist, weiß ich in der Hinsicht nicht. Ich würde es bezweifeln, glaube ich. Ja.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, also ich habe das Gefühl, wir gehen mit solchen Diskussionen dann fast fallen wir dann auf das Narrativ rein, nämlich das Narrativ, was ja über allem steht, nämlich nur mehr Geld wird es lösen. Und ich glaube, dass, also diesen Beweis muss der deutsche Fußballer erstmal für mich antreten. Denn es gab jetzt ganz, ganz lange immer mehr Geld. Dann gab es drei Krisen, die Kirchkrise, die Finanzmarktkrise 2009 und jetzt die Corona-Pandemie. Jeweils wurde es eng. Das muss man auch den Vereinen nicht immer gleich vorwerfen. Das ist letztlich ein Umlagegeschäft, was die machen. Also Theater, Bühnen, ging es auch schlecht, wenn sie nicht Aufführungen machen konnten. Also muss man jetzt auch nicht überdramatisieren aus ökonomischer Sicht. Aber warum sollen wir denn überhaupt dieses Narrativ noch so weiter bedienen? Ich habe mir jetzt auch in Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung wirklich schon hundertstelmal die Frage gestellt, warum guckt man denn nicht erstmal auf das, was man hat im deutschen Fußball? Und zwar ganz allgemein. Also wenn jetzt Aliens hier landen würden und die kämen von Mackenzie, also von dem Alien Mackenzie, und die würden sich dann den Fußball angucken, dann würden die ihm eine Marktanalyse machen. Und da würden die nämlich nicht nur auf TV-Rechte und nationale TV-Rechte usw. gucken, sondern dann würden die zum Beispiel gucken, ach, guck mal an, ihr habt immer noch mit dem DFB, trotz aller Dinge, die der DFB gemacht hat, den größten Sportverband der Welt. Sehr interessant. Wie viele Spieler von euch spielen richtig im Leistungssport, richtig guten Fußball? Oh, ist ja gar nicht so viel. Ist ja komisch. Da müssten wir mal ansetzen. Ach, guck mal an, ihr habt ja sogar in der 2. und 3. Liga richtig gute Zuschauerzahlen, ihr habt Stadien, die in der Regel in einem sehr guten Zustand sind, ihr habt da eine gewachsene Tradition. Das sehe ich gar nicht in allen anderen Ländern, zumindest nicht in dieser Ausprägung. Also es gibt ja auch Dinge, wo man sagen könnte, da können jetzt wiederum andere gar nicht den deutschen Fußball kopieren. Wir sehen es ja an den Kopien, die es innerhalb des deutschen Fußballs gibt. Du kannst Fan-Kultur nicht künstlich erzeugen. Das ist etwas Gewachsenes und dafür brauchst du 40 Jahre und wahrscheinlich wird in 50 Jahren könnte auch Rasenball Sport Leipzig dann ein ganz toll gewachsener Verein sein. Jetzt können sie es noch gar nicht sein. Das ist gar nicht möglich. Und ich stelle mir die Frage, warum wird über sowas so wenig diskutiert? Warum können wir das nicht in den Mittelpunkt stellen? Dieser Ligen, ich spreche da auch nicht nur von der ersten Liga, sondern auch von der zweiten und von der dritten Liga, die würde ich da auch gerne mitdenken, und dann darum ein Produkt bauen, was erstmal für sich genommen auf dem nationalen Markt Spaß macht. Und dann können wir doch mal gucken, was macht das mit internationaler Wettbewerbsfähigkeit? Geht die wirklich komplett flöten? Ich weiß es nicht. Und es ist auch wirklich dann für andere gar nicht mehr interessant, wenn da, es werden ja trotzdem Champions-League-Teilnehmer aus Deutschland kommen. Also man wird ja trotzdem deutschen Fußball in Anführungszeichen im Ausland sehen. Und ich find's erstaunlich, dass diese Diskussion so gar nicht geführt wird. Es kann aber halt auch sein, dass ich ein romantischer Depp bin. Ihr dürft's mir ruhig sagen.
Mich hat das alles so ein bisschen desillusioniert damals, als ich so tief in diese Champions-League-Reform eingestiegen bin. Da gab es viele Elemente, wo man gesagt hat, das kann doch echt nicht euer Ernst sein. Und das ist so furchtbar. Und eigentlich sind sich alle einig. Nur ein paar große waren halt dafür. Und die UEFA ließ sich dann zunächst nicht umstimmen, später dann doch. Und ich glaube die Tatsache, dass dieses ganze System Profifußball von der europäischen Ebene bis zur dritten, vielleicht noch bis zur Regionalliga, einfach ein Puzzlespiel von Einzelinteressen ist. Und jeder sucht und muss seinen eigenen Vorteil suchen in diesem, und das ist ein ganz wichtiges Stichwort, das du gerade gesagt hast, in diesem, wie hast du es genannt, Umlagebetrieb. Und wenn du so einen Umlagebetrieb hast, heißt das, dass die Einnahmenseite immer liefern muss, weil die Kostenseite fest steht und wächst. Und das hat zu all diesen Verwerfungen der letzten Jahre geführt. Und das, was du da gerade anstößt, ist ja eine gute Idee, aber eine systemkritische Grundsatzdiskussion, dazu kommt man ja gar nicht. Wie auch? Wer soll das sein? Wer soll das machen? Deswegen, ich habe im Nachhinein immer so ein bisschen bei diesem Wort Demut von Christian Seifert, ich nenne das immer dieses unerfüllbare Versprechen, weil es war klar, er ist ja nicht der Chef von den 36 Clubs. Er kann jetzt dann in dem Fall nur als der Krisenmanager sprechen und hat dieses Wort gesagt, was ihm jetzt immer wieder vorgehalten wird. Vielleicht bereut er es manchmal auch schon, weiß ich nicht. Aber dieses unerfüllbare Versprechen, dieses Zusammenspiel der Einzelinteressen, das zeigte sich ja auch bei dieser Abstimmung und so weiter. Ich meine, dass das obere Tabellendrittel der Bundesliga wahrscheinlich halbwegs geschlossen dafür war und das untere Tabellendrittel der zweiten Bundesliga wahrscheinlich im Großen und Ganzen dagegen war, das ist ja völlig klar. Das meine ich auch mit Einzelinteressen. Dann kommst du gar nicht auf einen gemeinsamen Nenner oder auf eine gemeinsame grundsätzliche Diskussion, die du gerade anstoßen willst. Aber es gibt keinen, der mit dir dieses Ding bis zum Ende ausdiskutiert. Außer mir, ich stehe zur Verfügung.
Ich würde gerne noch mal einen Punkt ansprechen, wo glaube ich aus Rücksicht auch auf andere nicht ernsthaft darüber diskutiert wird. Weil wenn wir mal ehrlich sind, wie viele fette Spiele hat die Bundesliga? Das ist eins pro Halbserie, nämlich Bayern gegen Dortmund. Das Gelaber vom Klassiker geht einem komplett auf den Sack, aber wenn man ehrlich ist, es ist das einzig fette Spiel, was die Bundesliga zu vermarkten hat. Und guck dir doch mal die Spielsager an, guck dir die Samstagnachmittagskonferenzen an. Da sind unglaublich viele Spiele, die wir natürlich so, wenn man als Journalist darüber arbeitet, kannst du nicht schreiben oder sagen, interessiert keinen. Aber wenn ich sonntags auf meinem Dorf-Sportplatz bin und dann läuft Bundesliga, du merkst es halt. Wenn Bremen gegen Schalke spielt, dann gehen die Leute in der Halbzeit rein. Wenn Mainz gegen Augsburg spielt, bleiben die Leute draußen, wenn es nicht gerade regnet, weil es sie nicht interessiert. Das hat auch nichts damit zu tun, ob diese Vereine gut arbeiten oder nicht. Das ist halt das Problem. Du kannst die Attraktivität eines Gesamtprodukts vermarkten. Du natürlich nur über die Attraktivität der Einzelteile. Und wir haben derzeit in der Bundesliga schlichtweg zu viele Einzelteile, die nicht attraktiv genug sind, um dafür auf dem ausländischen Markt super viel Kohle einzustreichen. So ehrlich müsste man bei der DFL mal sein. Ich glaube, die machen drei Kreuzzeichen, dass in der Relegation vielleicht Heidenheim gegen Schalke spielt und dann scheitert. Weil wenn du Schalke gegen HSV hast, hast du ein Nullsummenspiel. Das sagt natürlich nie einer, weil sie müssen ja auch irgendwo neutral bleiben. Aber das müssen wir jetzt heute Abend nicht. Und du kannst ja auch nicht sagen, schick Wolfsburg raus, schick Hoffenheim raus. Das geht natürlich nicht, weil die sportlich qualifiziert sind. Aber es ist nun mal Fakt, und da gibt es ja auch Untersuchungen, dass diese Vereine nicht ziehen, nicht attraktiv genug sind. Und dass die Bundesliga hinter Bayern und Dortmund ein extremes Attraktivitätsproblem hat.
Ja, völlige Zustimmung. Wenn du das genau betrachtest, diese Spiele von einigen Clubs, die du gerade genannt hast, wir werden auch älter. Unsere Jugend war geprägt davon, dass wir immer wussten, was bei Kaiserslautern gegen Stuttgart oder bei Hamburg gegen Bremen passiert. Das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen weniger so aus Fansicht, dass man sich für jedes Spiel interessiert, es geht jeweils auch um unser Alter, aber grundsätzlich hast du völlig recht. Aber du kannst die Bundesliga natürlich nicht voll machen nach Dauerkartenverkauf, sondern nach sportlicher, finanzieller, struktureller Qualifikation. Marcus war völlig recht, da gibt es auf jeden Fall ein Attraktivitätsproblem. Da gibt es ganz viele Spiele, die kaum jemanden wirklich interessieren. Und dann hat man immer dieses Spiel Richtung Saisonende. Wer geht hoch, wer steigt ab? Vor zwei Jahren hatten wir schon mal so eine Zusammenstellung der Bundesliga, wo einige gesagt haben, was ist da los? Jetzt haben wir noch mal eine, wo viele sagen werden, die sich gerade eine Zusammenstellung der Bundesliga andeutet. Ja, das wird auch gesehen, aber das ist vielleicht auch eher wiederum ein Thema auf dem nationalen Markt. Weil ich meine, in den USA ist da der FC Augsburg so viel uninteressanter als Werder Bremen für den Außenstehenden, der jetzt wirklich von weit weg kommt und sich gerade beginnt für die Bundesliga zu interessieren. Weiß ich halt nicht, aber national sind diese Unterschiede, die Markus gerade angesprochen hat, in der Attraktivität vollkommen da.
Aber, Danomanov, kannst du eine Liga in Gänze im ausländischen Markt interessant machen? Also wenn Barnumus gegen Southampton spielt oder Barnumus gegen Leicester, dann gucke ich das auch nicht. Und ansonsten, wenn Chelsea, Manchester United und Manchester City, gucke ich das schon gerne aus Gründen der Abneigung. Weil natürlich auch ganz guter Fußball da gezeigt wird. Und die haben halt mit Arsenal fünf, sechs fette Clubs. Das heißt, du hast mit Tottenham dann auch noch an jedem Spieltag minimum zwei gute Spiele. Und in der Bundesliga, wie gesagt, da würde ich mich jetzt wiederholen. Aber in Gänze eine Liga attraktiv zu vermarkten, ist für mich ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Also Barnumus gegen Leicester, da sind wir beide morgen auf der Fähre.
Da kommt halt noch so ein Effekt mit rein, den denken wir halt schon immer raus, weil wir halt wissen, dass wir uns sowieso schon im Bereich der Illusion sehr wahrscheinlich bewegen mit dieser Diskussion. Aber Tabellenkonstellationen können es natürlich noch spannend. Ich kann mich schon dran erinnern, als in der Serie A die Dominanz von Juwe gebrochen wurde und quasi das erstmals zu erkennen war, was wir jetzt gerade in seiner vollen Blüte erleben, nämlich Superfußball von vielen Teams, ein spannender, na gut, spannend war der Meisterschaftskampf nicht, aber man konnte sich zumindest mit Namouli sehr mitfreuen wegen der Geschichte. Aber als das losging vor drei, vier, fünf Jahren, da habe ich regelmäßig die Ergebnisse der Serie A gecheckt und dass ich die Spiele nicht geguckt habe, liegt daran, weil ich völlig krank bin und immer die Bundesligaspiele gucke, beruflich eben. Aber da habe ich regelmäßig gecheckt, weil das eben so eng war, weil es da innerhalb von wenigen Punkten die ersten fünf Plätze lagen, weil es mich interessiert hat, was macht jetzt Milan, was macht jetzt Inter. Also ich glaube, das ist schon noch ein Aspekt, der mit dazu kommt, wenn die Liga sich zusammenstaucht. Und ein bisschen erleben wir das ja jetzt. Wir nehmen auch vor dem 34. Spieltag. An diesem 34. Spieltag gibt es zum ersten Mal seit dem Dreißigjährigen Krieg kein Spiel, das nicht irgendeine Auswirkung hat. Also es gibt kein goldene Ananas-Spiel an diesem 34. Spieltag. Das ist ja fantastisch.
Das ist genau das, was Marcus gerade gesagt hat. Also diese Relevanz des letzten Spieltags, da kann man eine ganze Liga interessant machen. Das ist ja ein Punkt. Ich habe neulich nochmal in der Diskussion dazu gesagt, wenn ihr euch eine andere Liga ansieht... Also wir müssen jetzt darauf gucken, wir gucken Menschen in anderen Ländern auf die Bundesliga. Wenn ihr euch eine andere Liga ansieht, worauf schaut ihr? Guckt ihr in Italien darauf, ob Sassu Holo oder Salini Tana auf dem Conference League Playoff Platz steht? Oder guckt ihr, was oben im Titelkampf passiert? Natürlich guckt man erstmal auf den Titelkampf. Und der ist halt in der Bundesliga derzeit, mit der Ausnahme, alle elf Jahre ziemlich langweilig. Das ist jetzt halt ne Ausnahme. Du hast mal bei der Playoff-Diskussion das Bild geprägt, ein Pflaster für einen offenen Knochenbruch. Das würde ich hier auch verwenden. Also wir wissen genau, wie wütend die Leitung von Bayern München wahrscheinlich über diesen Ausgang der Bundesliga-Saison ist und was die nächsten Jahre passieren wird vielleicht. Das ist meine Annahme, was daraus ergeht. Also das wird man sich nicht gerne gefallen lassen, diese Abwertung. Und wenn Marcus sagt, wie kann man eine ganze Liga attraktiv machen, das geht natürlich vor allem über den Titelkampf. Und der ist halt, die aktuelle Saison ist eine Ausnahme, aber der ist eigentlich nicht da.
Jein, ich weiß es nicht. Also ich spiele immer noch einen Ton ein, der wieder von Michael Streuk kommt. Ich finde, der hatte schon noch ein paar andere Gedanken, die jetzt nicht nur auf Titelkampf abzielen.
Ich glaube schon auch, dass es sinnvoll und ratsam wäre, hier in eine breitere Diskussion einzusteigen, und nicht nur vier oder sechs Personen damit zu beauftragen, sondern wir brauchen einen breiten möglichsten Querschnitt aus der ersten und zweiten Liga und im Idealfall alle 36, die ihre Meinungen einbringen können und daraus am Ende versuchen, eine Strategie abzuleiten, die allen gerecht wird. Und ich bin der Meinung, wenn die Mehrheit sagt, wir wollen die Top-Clubs international konkurrenzfähig zu machen, ohne dass es meine Meinung sein muss, wenn das die Mehrheit sagt, dann ist das ein großer Bestandteil der Strategie. Aber diese Diskussion wird seit Jahren nicht geführt und es ist zwingend an der Zeit, darüber zu sprechen, was wollen wir? Wollen wir eben dem Primat des Geldes folgen und so viel wie möglich in die DFL holen an Geldern? Wollen wir die Interessanz, dass die erste und zweite Liga haben, wo einfach dauerhaft Auf- und Abstieg möglich ist und dass sich Vereine wie jetzt auch Union Berlin aus der zweiten Liga kommen in der ersten Liga etablieren können? Wollen wir die vollsten Stadien haben? Wollen wir die tollste Fanatmosphäre haben mit den größtmöglichen Stehplatz-Kontingenten? Wollen wir die dritte Liga vielleicht auch unter das Dach der ersten und zweiten Liga nehmen? Wollen wir die sozialste Liga der Welt werden? Das sind alles mögliche Entscheidungen, die am Ende stehen können, wenn man es offen und ehrlich diskutiert und nicht nur einer kleinen Gruppe folgt und sagt, die wollen das jetzt oder von Verantwortlichen ein Stück weit gesteuert. Ich glaube, das zeigt für mich dieses Abstimmungsverhalten gestern schon, dass es an der Zeit ist, breiter zu diskutieren und nicht wie in der Vergangenheit einem gewissen vermeintlichen Meinungsbild zu folgen, das aber gar nicht das Meinungsbild der 36 Klubs sein muss.
Guter Mann, hört sich alles gut an.
Ja, es sind vor allem andere Töne, als die man sonst hört. Lasst uns mal versuchen, dann so langsam, weil wir werden jetzt die Probleme der DFL nicht lösen und wir werden auch kein abschließendes Urteil fällen können, denn das ist alles jetzt gerade ein Prozess, der im Werden ist. Inklusive der interessanten Frage, wer wird denn jetzt dann irgendwann mal DFL-Geschäftsführer oder Geschäftsführerin? Ich denke, wir alle haben viele Namen gehört. Müssen wir jetzt an der Stelle nicht spekulieren, denn wir werden es erfahren. Im Juli soll es ja soweit sein und dann können wir uns ja zur Not nochmal treffen, wenn das jetzt irgendwie ganz skandalös ist. Aber nachdem wir jetzt schon so ein bisschen gezeigt haben, die Tragweite dieser Diskussion, gleichzeitig die angespannte Situation, also irgendetwas muss passieren und gleichzeitig die zwischenzeitlich vorhandene Schärfe im Akzeptieren oder im Verkaufen dieser Ablehnung, die zumindest darauf hindeutet, da gibt es jetzt ein bisschen Arbeit, die zu tun ist. Marcus, was glaubst du denn, was wird bleiben letztlich von diesem Investoren-Deal, der jetzt nicht zustande gekommen ist? Wie wird sich die DFL danach entwickeln?
Das ist schwierig. Ich glaube allerdings, dass sich die Wogen erstmal glätten werden. Wir sind jetzt beim Saisonfinale, dann kommt eine Sommerpause, da werden sich alle erstmal beruhigen, werden ein bisschen Urlaub machen. Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass, so hieß es ja auch gestern, dass die nächste tonusgemäße Versammlung der DFL im August sein wird. Wenn diese Wahl des neuen Geschäftsführers, Geschäftsführerin oder auch der Doppelspitze ist ja auch im Gespräch, ruhig abläuft und dass die Vereine da einen Konsens finden, glaube ich, dass man sich dann wieder beruhigt, wie das ja so häufig bei solchen Sachen der Fall ist, und sich dann vielleicht tatsächlich eine AG-Zukunftsszenarien wählt, die nicht nur vier Mitglieder hat, wo dann, ich sag's mal einfach, ein Quoten-Zweitligges dabei ist und die beiden Geschäftsführer und dann noch ein paar Treter von Bayern München, sondern dass man sagt, wir setzen uns mal in größerer Runde sehr regelmäßig zusammen. Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich habe mir jetzt ein Protokoll von einer Mitgliederversammlung gesehen, wenn man mit 36 Clubs, wo die so heterogen sind, wo es so viel zu besprechen gibt, da gerade mal für zweieinhalb Stunden nach Frankfurt kommt, ist es schon ziemlich erstaunlich und in welchem Turnus die auch tagen. Also da fehlt es meiner Ansicht nach auch an so einem Kreis, der halt häufiger zusammentritt und dann die Probleme auch benennt. Vielleicht gibt es den und wir wissen nichts davon. Ja, das glaube ich, kann gut passieren, dass der Laden komplett explodiert, wie es gestern so teilweise manche befürchtet haben, das glaube ich nicht. Da hängen halt auch viele Sachen dran, diese angeblichen Pläne, die schon in der Schublade liegen, ich weiß gar nicht, da müsste man auch mal an die Juristen fragen, ob das überhaupt möglich ist, dass sie sich abspallen. Würde ich jetzt mal im ersten Moment auch bezweifeln, auch bei den laufenden Verträgen, was wir ja schon gesagt haben. Die Prognose ist schwierig, hängt glaube ich schon ein bisschen davon ab, wie der Meisterkampf in den nächsten Jahren auch wird. Ich sehe es genauso wie Chaled, wir werden alle 11 Jahre mal einen Meister haben, der dann, wenn die Bayern schwächelt, da ist, wer immer das auch sein mag. Denke ich mal, dass sie irgendwoher Geld bekommen werden. Dann müssen sie es halt aus dem Topf nehmen, der jetzt schon da ist und das sind ja über eine Milliarde Euro im Jahr. Und dann wären sie digitaler und internationaler. Ob das dann zum Erfolg führt, keine Ahnung.
Ja, wünschenswert, damit ich nicht missverstanden werde, wäre das, was du gesagt hast und was Michael Streul gesagt hat, um jetzt nicht das zu wiederholen, was Markus gesagt habe, dem ich grundsätzlich beiflichten möchte. Aber eine Grundsatzdiskussion, was das sein soll, was das werden soll, wie man das macht, die wäre natürlich wünschenswert. Aber Markus sprach ja auch an, wie heterogen diese Clubs sind. Wenn halt 36 Clubs in 36 Einzelgruppen fallen oder vielleicht nur in ein paar mehr Gruppen fallen, dann wirst du schwer eine Lösung finden, die allen gerecht wird. Also wenn du sagst, du willst eben nicht nur zwei Spitzenclubs nach vorne treiben in Europa, dann werden diese beiden Spitzenclubs vielleicht sagen, okay, das wollen wir aber nicht. Und wir empfinden das als ambitionslos, was der Rest hier von uns verlangt. Ich glaube, es wird schwer sein und schwer bleiben, da eine Lösung zu finden, die allen gerecht wird. Ich persönlich finde es glaube ich erst mal ganz gut, dass dieses Einnahmen nach vorne ziehen vom Tisch ist, weil ich glaube, dass da auch eine Gefahr drin bestanden hätte, dass man da ein Prinzip etabliert, was dann auch weiter hätte fortgeführt werden können. Also du verkaufst einmal 12,5% gegen alle Proteste und Widersprüche. Bei den nächsten 12,5% wird es halt keine großen Proteste mehr geben, weil dann ist es ein etabliertes Prinzip. Dann hängst du, um jetzt mal ein böses Bild zu benutzen, an der Nadel und brauchst irgendwann den nächsten Schuss, um das Niveau zu halten, auf dem du dich dann befindest und so weiter. Von daher glaube ich, ist das an der Stelle nicht die falscheste Entscheidung gewesen, was jetzt auf Dauer die richtige sein wird. Wie Markus, da bin ich jetzt auch nicht mit dem schlussendlichen Rat betraut.
Ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass wir da in ein paar Jahren zurückblicken werden und dann sehen, dass was quasi vorher ökonomisch schon passiert ist, das hat sich quasi an dieser Entscheidung zum ersten Mal innerhalb des Verbandes gezeigt. Ökonomisch trifft es es eben soweit auseinander, dass es ein Spannungsfeld gibt innerhalb der Liga. Da muss es zu Rissen kommen und die Risse siehst du dann bei solchen Abstimmungen, die Risse siehst du bei Aussagen von Watzke und Hellmann. Ich werde jetzt nicht mehr einspielen, was Andreas Rettich mir gegenüber so gesagt hat, aber es fiel das Wort Beleidigte und dann noch etwas, was man auf ein Brot schmieren kann, wenn man das noch essen möchte. Und ich glaube, an solchen Dingen siehst du eine Gesamtsituation. Ich glaube, dass es nicht nur an dem schlecht aufgelegten Prozess lag und an der fehlenden Transparenz und an dem, dass ein Vertreter hat auch mir gegenüber gesagt, ja vielleicht haben auch manche Vereine gar nicht verstanden, was wir da eigentlich machen wollten. Ich glaube nicht, dass das das Problem war. Ich glaube, dass da unterschätzt wird, dass sich an solchen Entscheidungen vielleicht auch ein größeres Missverhältnis zeigt. Und das Missverhältnis ist da, das Missverhältnis wird immer wieder thematisiert. Das Missverhältnis wird immer über die sportliche Einflugschneise thematisiert, über die Meisterschaften des FC Bayern. Sie wird aber in Managerkreisen ja eben viel eher über das thematisiert, was du, Khaled, ja vorhin auch so schön beschrieben hast, eben die Geldströme und wie ungleich die eben auseinandergehen. Und vor allem alle sehen ja, was passiert. Du hast es ja vorhin schon gesagt, jetzt dann mit neuer Champions-League-Reform und so weiter und so fort. Also dieses Auseinanderdriften, das wird noch für mehr Spannungen sorgen. Und das muss in die eine oder andere Richtung sich entladen. Und die eine Entladungsmöglichkeit ist, dass dann diejenigen nach oben entwischen, die eben in die Super League wollen und die eben zu den Superreichen gehören. Und die andere Möglichkeit der Entladung, und da sehe ich aber durchaus auch eine Möglichkeit für, ist, dass die... Wie formuliere ich das jetzt? Also wenn ich mich mit der DFL beschäftige und mit dem Vorgänger, also dann mit Liga-Präsident Gerhard Meyer-Volfelder und so weiter, dann sehe ich schon eine Tendenz dazu, dass es schon immer so war, dass die sportlich und ökonomisch erfolgreichen Klubs eher in den Spitzenpositionen, dieses Liga-Verbandes und später der DFL dann waren als die anderen. Und das ist ja eigentlich, muss ja eigentlich gar nicht so sein. Also früher hat man das auch so begründet, na das sind die, die am besten wirtschaften und Meyer-Volfelder waren natürlich auch super vernetzt und so weiter und so fort. Und dann hatten wir diese Phase mit mehreren Geschäftsführern, müssen wir jetzt nicht ins Detail reingehen. Aber vielleicht ist das etwas, was sich verändern wird. Vielleicht kommt jetzt ein neuer, ja wahrscheinlich Mann, ihr rein von außerhalb. Frau würde ich mir auch wünschen, halte ich aber nach dem, was ich gehört habe, für sehr unrealistisch aktuell. Der es schafft, die Liga erst mal wieder zu vereinen und der aber dann diese Spannung von unten her löst. Weil in eine Richtung muss es sich lösen. Entweder hebt man das untere Niveau an und man kommt damit näher den oberen und die können aber wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch international konkurrentfähig sein, weil ganz so schlimm ist es dann doch nicht. Oder sie entwischen in die andere, obere Richtung. Und ich möchte als letzten O-Ton einmal noch mal Ija Kencik einspielen. Denn der hat nämlich noch so zwei Aspekte mit angesprochen, die wir jetzt nicht so wirklich mit dabei hatten. Die müssen wir jetzt auch glaube ich nicht mehr ausdiskutieren. Aber ich fand es interessant, dass er, der ja auch so nah in diesem ganzen Prozess mit drin war, das noch zur Sprache gebracht hat. Und damit kommen wir nämlich am Schluss auch noch mal zu dieser gescheiterten Entscheidung und damit schließt sich dann vielleicht ein zwei Stunden langer Kreis.
Erstmal muss man sagen, kann es durchaus sein, dass einfach wirklich genug Clubs das wollen. Und dann ist es auch egal, wie es präsentiert wurde, ob auf dem Wilbetablett oder etwas sperrig. Oder das spielt dann keine Rolle. Wenn man sich will, dann will man sich. Aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass vielleicht sozusagen diejenigen, die es verstanden haben, die muss ich nicht mehr abholen. Aber vielleicht diejenigen, die tatsächlich Mühe mit der Materie hatten und die da jetzt vielleicht mehr Fragen hatten. Dafür war möglicherweise das Ganze auch zu komplex. Und war auch die DFL in einer suboptimalen Situation, wo man darf es nicht vergessen, immer zwei interimistische Geschäftsführer, die übrigens nebenbei noch der eine um die Champions League kämpfen, der andere um die Europa League und den Pokal noch engagiert sind. Die auch massig zu tun haben bei sich zu Hause. Also kann man vielleicht sagen, ja, waren die Ressourcen nicht ganz vorhanden, um umfassend diejenigen abzuholen, die es nicht auf Anhieb verstanden haben und vielleicht auch gar nicht die Zeit hatten, gerade kleinere Clubs. Aber man kann auch sagen, vielleicht hätte man die Öffentlichkeit noch viel mehr abholen sollen und eben nicht eine fachinteressierte Öffentlichkeit, sondern eben den, ich sage jetzt in Anführung seines gemeinen Fans, dass der das halt auch versteht, ohne vorher, sage ich jetzt mal, sich mit Investment-Thinking auseinandersetzen zu müssen, sondern wirklich, wo man sagt, erkläre mir das Geschäft in 10 Sekunden oder in 30 Sekunden. Ich glaube, am Schluss ist es wirklich eine Mischung und die zeigt eben auch, dass der deutsche Fußball oder hat aber maß gezeigt, dass der deutsche Fußball eben anders funktioniert. Ich glaube, wenn in England die Club-Owners zusammenkommen oder ihre Abgesandten schicken, dann sind die alle tief im Thema drin und dann reden die über Business und dann geht es weiter. Und in Deutschland musst du nicht nur die Club-Vertreter, du musst auch die Clubgremien und du musst die Fans und die muss die große Öffentlichkeit oder ganz Fußballdeutschland oder ganz Deutschland mitnehmen. Und vielleicht sind das eben auch Learnings für die Zukunft. Jetzt unabhängig von Investorenfragen oder nicht, aber dass man sagt, Fußballbusiness ist etwas, was halt ganz im Sinne von Volkssport halt auch von 80 Millionen mitdiskutiert wird. Und die haben nachher Einfluss auf die Entscheidung. Anders als in anderen Ligen. Vielleicht sind das die Learnings.
Die Learnings. Ja, vielleicht ist ja Fußball dann doch mehr als nur Fußballbusiness. Vielleicht müssen wir die 80 Millionen mitnehmen. Jetzt haben wir erstmal, ich habe euch zwei mitgenommen und ihr habt unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer mitgenommen. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit in dieser intensiven Phase. Wie ich weiß, ja auch noch kurz vor 34 im Spieltag. Und anderen Verpflichtungen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Marcus Bark, der at Artus69 auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst.
Ja, ich danke für die Einladung. Hat viel Spaß gemacht.
Ja, das glaube ich dir. Und ich vermute, Chaled Nahar wird es nicht anders gehen. Ihr könnt ihm als Chaled Nahar natürlich auch auf allen Plattformen eurer Wahl folgen. Chaled, jetzt hast du Urlaub.
Ja, jetzt ist erstmal Schluss. Und alle Plattformen nicht. Ich benutze eigentlich nur noch Twitter.
Antizykluschandeln. Sehr gut.
Genau. Richtig.
Alle anderen habe ich eigentlich weggelassen zuletzt.
Danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Das war mein Gespräch mit Chaled Nahar und Marcus Bark. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich danke sehr allen meinen Gästen. Nicht nur diesen beiden, sondern auch Michael Streul, Andreas Rettig, Ilja Kentzik und all denjenigen, die noch bei ausgeschaltetem Mikrofon mit mir sprechen wollten. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, das war nicht das letzte Mal, dass wir über dieses Thema direkt oder indirekt gesprochen haben im Rasenfunk. Ihr habt es ja auch im Fazit dieser Folge gehört. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und noch mal an dieser Stelle der Hinweis. Den ganzen Rasenfunk gibt es nur, weil ihr ihn finanziell ermöglicht. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Wir verzichten auf Payrolls, wir verzichten auf Sponsoren und auf Werbung, weil wir eben darauf setzen, dass ihr uns tragt. Und ganz viele von euch tun das schon. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund, macht's gut, ciao! Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch. Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.